turning now to the landmark legal case
against former president Donald Trump
after he was indicted on charges related
to a hush money scheme he told followers
on social media last night that he's
flying to New York today and he will
show up for his arraignment tomorrow
he's also been trying to stir up anger
at the judge and others in the case
Robert Costa is outside the courthouse
in New York Bob good morning
good morning Nate we will not know what
specifically is in this indictment until
it is unsealed tomorrow but former
president Trump and Republicans are
already on the attack
he's gearing up for a battle former
president Trump and his legal team are
preparing to fight what his lawyer Joe
takapina is calling a political
persecution of course I very much
anticipate a motion to dismiss coming
because there's no law that fits this
the former president is expected to
appear in court on Tuesday afternoon
escorted by NYPD officers and Secret
Service agents there CBS News senior
legal analyst Ricky cleeman says he'll
be processed like any other defendant he
will have his picture taken which
becomes a mug shot he will have his
fingerprints taken electronically like
any other defendant at this point in
time the indictment remains sealed but a
source familiar tells CBS news that
Trump will likely be charged with
falsifying business records in the first
degree a felony stemming from his
alleged role in hush Money Paid to adult
film star Stormy Daniels back in 2016. I
should not be held accountable for
Donald Trump's 30 Deeds Michael Cohen a
key witness for the prosecution alleges
Trump directed him to make the payment
demons to Daniels Cohen has served time
in prison partly for his role in that
Exchange in an interview with CBS News
he says this investigation goes beyond
his word let the documents and the
evidence speak for itself for weeks
Trump has gone on the offensive going
after Manhattan district attorney Alvin
bragan now the judge assigned to the
case Trump wrote on his social media
site Friday judge Juan mershon hates me
Republicans came to Trump's defense this
weekend including potential competitors
in the 2024 race they're trying to do
all these legal gymnastics to try to act
like it's a felony he has an agenda that
is not the rule of law but not all GOP
Rivals are voicing support former
Arkansas governor Aza Hutchinson
announced on Sunday he's running for
president and thinks Trump should get
out of the race the office is more
important than any individual person and
so for the sake of the office of the
presidency I do think that's too much of
a sideshow and distraction
after Tuesday's arraignment Trump plans
to return to Florida where he will speak
to reporters at Mar-A-Lago all while his
attorneys keep close tabs on the ongoing
Federal investigations of trump on
January 6 and unclassified records
Natalie
Bob thanks for keeping a watch there for
us